if you ever want to see how some of the
locals in the cosmopolitan resource of
Marbella spend their time just head to
the pores every morning fishermen
arrived back here after their night out
at sea
it's good then that I'm his fish weighed
two to three kilos it tastes great when
you prepared any other the local cache
is sold in the town's market hall
michelin-starred chef Diego Del Rio
likes to taste what's on offer himself
malaga edy na muna Oh Laura field
landscape around Monica is varied we've
got to see valleys mountains we have
major rivers that flow into the sea and
perfect conditions for this type of
seafood exist at the point where the
estuaries join the sea en este tipo de
memory
the chef trusts his fishmonger but he
has a handy tip for anyone who wants to
check whether prawns are really fresh
what are you if they weren't really
fresh the feelers would break off if you
go shopping with Diego Del Rio you'll
notice that he chooses his products with
great care sampling aroma and taste and
asking the right questions important if
you want to get the very best quality
his restaurant elago belongs to a small
golf club on the edge of marbella it
serves snacks during the day and top
class cuisine at night
gente que viene DOTA parte del mundo
just so come here from abroad aren't
used to our flavors no comprende and so
you have to change the dish a little
local antithetical to our guests tastes
a lot of a lovely intellect for euromaxx
he's preparing a cold twice garlic soup
its name is a bit misleading because
almonds are its main ingredient the
region is also Spain's chief almond
producer first of all make a creamy
puree from almonds garlic bread and a
little sherry in a blender then add
water and olive oil but don't use extra
virgin oil or the soup will turn out
better season with salt pass the soup
through a sieve and in just a few
minutes the soup is ready
yo man take one with Iran trabajando en
in the past when peasants used to work
in the fields and didn't have much time
they would knock something together for
lunch using the ingredients at hand
almonds bread a little olive oil
nowadays this soup is regarded as the
queen of sips the world's most famous
restaurants have it on their menus under
the Toronto the chef gives the soup a
little twist with the addition of mango
or alternatively with grapes apples or
other fruits add coriander chives and a
little oil then peel and salt the prawns
if you don't have a brûlée torch then
just briefly fry them in a hot pan it's
important that they remain almost raw
inside I'm a born another prawns have a
delicate sweet taste that goes very well
with the almond garlic soup and mango
which adds a fruity note and I add a
little coriander and chives to round it
off they say well you need a blender and
then it's time to serve the sweet mango
is placed at the bottom then add prawns
and herbs
the soup is added at the table
and there you have it a refreshing
starter for hot summer days
you